this is further proof that long live the
sponge michelle
follow your oddities and fly your freak
frag
i would like to say that if you can't
love yourself how in the hell are you
going to look over there
my name is shea coulee and i didn't come
to slay
i came to win our
last four reigning queens are all black
queens which has been a really
amazing thing to see
[Laughter]
in the moment there how does it make you
feel to know you're part of this kind of
legacy this moment of four in a row um
it it's kind of a trip because uh like
long before
i got on drag race i was a fan of the
show i watched it
and the one personal critique i always
had was
i always just felt like specifically in
the way that black queens
were received by the fan base like we
were never given
the same opportunities to shine our
careers didn't take off
afterwards in the same ways and
so it was at first
mind-blowing for me to be a part of this
legacy
and now it's less shocking and more just
it
it feels really good to know that people
in general are more willing to like
step back and like check their biases
and be like
i like this queen but uh what are the
reasons why
i like her what are the reasons i'm not
following these girls and i think the
more we have these conversations
like the better the better the future of
drag race is going to be because
clearly black excellence exists
and i think it's about time that we've
we've been given the props for
all the work we put in i think that the
rupaul's drag race
in itself the franchise has always
celebrated queens of color
um but i i think the piece of the puzzle
that people miss is
quite often the fans pick the winner
when the competition
wraps opportunities and and
work and jobs come almost solely from
what is your social media following and
the fans do decide that and the fans
make it clear um
at the end of each season who is their
winner and who is not
um um and quite often you will have
someone
that was a winner or in the top three of
their season
sitting at home while someone that maybe
went home fourth or fifth
is touring around the world and it's
because um um at the end of the day the
true outcome of rupaul's drag race is a
popularity contest
well and it it does feel that sometimes
the black queens almost have to defend
their art
more than some of the white queens and
evie you kind of just had a moment with
katya having to
do this because there's a a snarky line
in
her and trixie's book about what you
wore to drag con
yeah have you been able to talk things
out with katja since i feel like it
opened a dialogue at least with a fandom
i'm glad it opened a dialogue with the
fandom which is the reason that i even
responded to that that like because
i think the fans deserve it more than
katya deserves it
and i i think if katya like wanted
to like have a chat about how and why
it's messed up that
she decided to publish a book
and include a whole non-sequitur passage
on why this one specific queen of color
is garbage and why she doesn't look good
and why her drag is bad i would love to
have that conversation with her
but she's still operating from her
place of privilege where she if you look
at just like like asia was saying if you
look at our follower accounts like
she is doing way better than me
she's staying way more books she's being
way busier and i
honestly just don't think she's at a
place right now where she knows how to
check her privilege
okay and probably a conversation to have
before you put it in print than one
that's what i would have done but that's
why i wanted to respond to it because i
think the fans deserve to know
my perspective i stayed silent for the
better part of a year while i received
like
death threats like racist hate mail
people
on the regular calling me like garbage
or saying that
my smelly ass deserved to die and all of
this
and i i just took it because i know that
as a representative for this show i had
to
be strong and i had to be forward but
there's also got to be a certain point
where you're like okay
okay i understand nobody wants to hear
the flaws called out
but the way you perceive black queens
the way you perceive
what i'm capable of doing is is already
in an
unfair system i think that yes and no
because there are
like katya is coming from a place also
when you think of drag you have to kind
of like hit a lot of bullet points when
you're doing drag
traditional drag and kind of when you're
go on drag race you kind of like sign up
for those bullet points too
so i think that katya coming from a
place and saying that
evie wearing like smudged eyeliner and a
t-shirt dress
and like making a joke about a hundred
thousand dollars i don't necessarily
see a huge privilege or huge racism
like point behind that and i hope that
that's like kind of something that
we don't get too focused on because we
are so
i mean we're judging facts you know so
we're always going to have something to
say
and i do agree that maybe in a published
book was not the setting to
voice those things that's more of a
tweet or maybe just a text
or an instagram comment i had this
conversation with evie and i think it
was that
she just felt like um some people can
you know though
they'll kind of jump on somebody and but
they'll like excuse
others but yeah
um i definitely think a lot of the
queens of color are not as
appreciated or like asia is one of my
favorite
um points she was really popular before
drag race um
in the pageant industry or you know
circuit and
i just feel like sometimes they're not
as appreciated
as you know i will say that asia's point
in that work the world docu series where
she said
like she doesn't necessarily think the
fan base is racist but the fact that
they're like
the fan base they can connect to
a white blonde girl more so because
there's just more that make up the fan
base
that was a very good point you look out
in the audience and you don't see
anybody that looks like you you
shouldn't be
surprised when they come to the meet and
greet and don't want to take a picture
with you
so how is vegas review different from
what we've seen on work
i mean work the world itself is just a
different experience because
you go to sleep on a bus and you wake up
every day in a different city
so you're you're kind of getting a peek
behind the curtain
at our lives and what it's what it's
like to be a drag queen
but with the vegas review like you
get to see us live a full life instead
of being like
where am i what city is this what coffee
am i drinking oh
definitely and i also think you know one
thing with work the world we're normally
in front
of die hard drag race fans and the vega
show is somewhat different because
about 80 percent of the audience each
night are people that are
you know in vegas to have a good time
they see our show
it's like oh i want to go watch this and
they may not be as familiar
with the television show as other people
so it's um a little bit
more of a task to get them um
to understand who we are and what we do
um
and also i think or at least for me you
know with work the world we have a lot
more
creative control over our portions of
the show and what we present in the show
um and the vegas show you know we're
coming into something that has already
been created
um with us in mind but already been
created so it's a completely different
as an artist it's a completely different
um vibe
so like in work the world um we get you
get a little bit of our personal life
but i really think this docu series
showcases
what is happening in our personal life
just as much as what you're seeing on
stage
so i think it's really cool to see that
part i i don't think we've seen it even
to work the world i don't think it's
been this
close to home for us